Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim und ich begrüße euch zur
85. Folge von UKW und nachdem wir letztes Mal wieder eine kleine D-Tour gemacht haben, um mal in Großbritannien nach dem Rechten zu sehen und zu schauen, was da denn alles so passiert ist. Äh kehren wir jetzt wieder hier zu unserem Dauerbrenner zurück. Corona mit mir und mit
Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Die Sendung, wo wir immer versuchen ein wenig,
Text zu äh schaffen und nachdem wir jetzt irgendwie so ein Sommer und auch noch so ein bisschen so eine Herbst äh der der hm gepflegten Langeweile gemacht haben und nur ab und zu mal was kommentieren wollten, habe ich so das Gefühl, wir sind jetzt schon wieder zurückkommandiert an äh an Deck
weil die der des Shithass äh äh Hits in the Fan.
Ja nie waren äh die Zahlen äh höher wie heute. Äh kann man da vielleicht äh sagen und ja weil nicht alle Zahlen aber viele Zahlen.
Genau, also die Inzidenzen sind auf jeden Fall Out of Control, man äh liest jetzt schon je nach Bundesland äh vierstellige Werte.
Vor allem je nach Altersgruppe, das werden wir gleich alles nochmal durchgehen. Ähm grundsätzlich.
Ist auch alles gleichzeitig scheiße, Krankenhäuser sind äh überlastet, insbesondere sind die Intensivstationen überlastet und das äh auch deshalb, weil natürlich auch die Intensivstationen letzten,
ja, sehr viel Personal verloren haben und überhaupt gar nicht mehr in der Lage sind, die Kapazitäten zu anzubieten, die man im letzten Jahr noch gesehen hat.
Impfzentren sind überlastet, vor allem weil sie halt weitgehend geschlossen wurden und das Personal reduziert wurde und jetzt fällt auf einmal allen ein, dass man ja dann doch noch mal alle boostern muss so. Ich meine, das ist eine Erkenntnis, hier hätte man auch schon im Juli haben müssen eigentlich, aber irgendwie äh hat da keiner drüber nachgedacht. Jetzt wollen sie wieder alle impfen. Jetzt
gibt's äh keine Termine. Die Ärzte sind überlastet, weil sie natürlich sich grade im Herbst und im Winter ohnehin mit viel Infektionskrankheiten rumschlagen müssen und jetzt noch die ganze
Belastung dazu. Es geht also wie immer hin und her und vor allem
sind die äh Politiker überlastet, insbesondere die ausgehende Regierung und in gewisser Hinsicht wahrscheinlich auch schon die
neu anstehende Regierungen in Deutschland. Das ist ein totales Desaster. Niemand will für irgendwas irgendeine Verantwortung übernehmen. Alle sind total überrascht.
Alles kam vollkommen unerwartet und äh damit hätte ja auch keiner rechnen können, dass jetzt irgendwie Wissenschaftler auf einmal irgendwie.
Situation vorhersagen können, gibt da diverse Zitate, die im Netz rumgehen, sei es von Drosten, sei es von äh Viola Prisemann et cetera. Alle, die sich damit beschäftigen, auch auf Twitter, die ganzen äh ehrenamtlichen Daten,
die dort immer wieder Modellrechnungen machen. Alle haben eigentlich im Wesentlichen immer wieder dasselbe gesagt, nämlich im Kern,
nicht genug geimpft bekommen, dann kriegen wir die nächste Welle. Jetzt ist sie da und sie ist in da in full glory vor zwei Wochen haben wir sie.
Beginnen sehen und jetzt äh ist sie halt schon an einem Punkt, wie du eben schon gesagt hast, wie wir sie so bisher nicht gehabt haben. Das heißt, die vierte Welle.
Wird die schlimmste gewesen sein und während wir bisher noch äh immer von diesem Effekt sprechen konnten,
dass durch die Impfung viele Leute ja zumindest vor Tod geschützt sind, ist die extrem hohe Inzidenz, aber auch die nachlassende Impfwirkung in Kombination jetzt leider das Rezept, dass auch diese Gewissheit,
zumindest in den nächsten paar Monaten erstmal verfliegen wird.
Bevor wir auf die Zahlen gucken, äh kann ich noch stolz verkünden, dass ich's äh schon zu meiner Booster-Impfung geschafft habe. Ich habe, glaube ich, grade rechtzeitig noch so ähm
den Absprung äh geschafft und einen Ort gefunden, der es äh nicht ganz so ernst genommen hat mit dieser bekloppten Sechs-Monate-Regelung.
Die ich nicht verstanden habe und auch immer noch nicht verstehe. Ja, also in Israel ist halt die Situation so
wurde geboostert, was das Zeug hält und da gilt man nach sechs Monaten als nicht mehr vollständig geimpft, wäre man in Deutschland nicht vor diesen sechs Monaten überhaupt auch nur dahin gehen darf.
Ja? Äh vollkommen unklar und was ich noch erzählen muss, es war wirklich so lustig. Also ich habe äh einen Termin wahrnehmen können hier in ähm,
Havelhöhe sagte das was Pavel.
Ja, ja, ja.
Berlin Havelhürdestündchen anthroposophisch geführtes Krankenhaus.
Es ist da irgendwie auch im Wald, ne, so.
Ja, es
schön am Wald und Havelhöhe heißt es deshalb, weil es halt eigentlich an der Havel ist, aber an so einer Klippe, also man blickt quasi so ein bisschen von oben auf die Havel. Alles äh sehr romantisch und so weiter. Auch eine sehr äh populäre Geburtsklinik. Hat natürlich, wie das eben bei solchen anthroposophischen Veranstaltungen ist, auch so einen gewissen Schwobelfaktor, aber der hat sich
nicht gezeigt, schon gar nicht in dem Impfzentrum, was sie dort nämlich aufgezogen haben und das hat wirklich sehr akkurat funktioniert, muss ich sagen. Also es ist zwar überschaubar, alles andere als so ein Riesen-Impfzentrum, wie.
Das jetzt hier in der Stadt zusammengezogen wurde, aber die haben da einfach freundlich und bestimmt einfach geimpft.
Und ja, so habe ich's äh jetzt mein Ziel auch erreicht und habe ähm.
Da auch noch mal kurz Rücksprache gehalten kurz vorher, aber habe mich jetzt bei meinem dritten Impfgang für Moderna entschieden und hab's also jetzt geschafft, die AstraZeneca Biontech äh moderner Kombiimpfe zu haben.
Mhm.
Der Arzt den ich dann gefragt hatte ob was sie denn da noch zu sagen würden. Meinte er dann so ja ja das haben bei uns auch alle äh wir nennen das die Jamaika-Impfung.
Er er konnte mir nicht so ganz genau erklären, warum eigentlich ich vermute mal, einfach weil's halt drei Farben sind, ohne dass es da jetzt eine spezifische Zuordnung gibt.
Äh mhm.
Ähm ich persönlich nenn's äh für mich einfach die YOLO-Impfung.
Hau rein, ist mir egal, Hauptsache Impfe. Ja und äh ich hab's auch beim dritten Impfstoff geschafft, keine nennenswerten Nebenwirkungen zu haben. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das gemacht habe, aber ist bei mir einfach irgendwie so.
Äh weißt du zufällig, ob der moderner Booster auch die volle Dosis äh äh.
Mittlerweile ist es nur noch die halbe Dosis. Also sie hatten glaube ich vor äh vier Wochen.
Seit wann mit moderner geboostert wird, aber äh zu Beginn haben sie die volle Dosis der normalen Impfung genommen. Das sind glaube ich diese 1hundert Mikroliter.
Und die haben sie mittlerweile auf fünfzig reduziert, weil wohl bei vielen die Reaktionen relativ stark war. Freundin von mir hatte das auch und meinte so, ja, es wäre schon ein bisschen tough gewesen. Ich, wie gesagt, scheine,
Immun gegen Immunreaktionen zu sein. Ich bin da überhaupt keine Referenz, leider.
Aber na ja gut, also ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus, dass ich ähm bei drei Versuchen jetzt auch zumindest zwei richtige Impfungen erhalten haben sollte. Alles andere wäre ein bisschen unwahrscheinlich, zumal ich das auch immer an drei verschiedenen Orten gehabt habe.
Als bist du dran, Pavel.
Ja, ja, ja, ich äh wie gesagt, ich ich hatte ja auch versucht, ich ich bin ja
sagen eine Woche später äh dran. Deswegen dachte ich na ja gut dann wenn du dich hast äh dann letzte Woche impfen lassen, dann warte ich noch eine eine Woche, dann ist es bei mir auch. Sind,
dann bei mir sicherlich auch die sechs Monate um. Aber innerhalb dieser Woche ähm sind irgendwie auch andere Leute auf die Idee gekommen
äh dass Sie sich Boostern lassen möchten oder impfen lassen möchten und äh ja äh ich habe dann ich weiß nicht bestimmt eine halbe, dreiviertel Stunde in dem Doktor Lip,
gebrowst äh und ähm da waren zwar jede Menge Impftermine bei Ärzten, aber jedes Mal, wenn ich mir dann einen Klicken.
Wollte, so konkret ist dann meistens im letzten Schritt poppte dann irgendwas auf, das sagte dann, ja aber leider nehmen wir keine Neupatienten auf für irgendwie wenn's ums,
geht ähm so und äh ja und bei Impfzentren war irgendwie auch nix mehr zu,
finden ähm so also innerhalb von einer Woche schlagartig äh ja
praktisch alle Impftermine erstmal weg, weil also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ich irgendwie noch äh was was finden werde jetzt in der kommenden Woche, aber äh ja, das das ging halt jetzt plötzlich so
ratzfatz und äh ja jetzt wird ja auch Biontech knapp.
Gerade beziehungsweise nee, ich weiß nicht, ob's knapp wird, aber zumindest liegt wohl zu viel moderner auf Lager und äh wisst weshalb jetzt gerade heute neue Nachricht ja äh will wohl wollen sie wohl
Biontech zurückhalten, damit die Modernare Reserven abgearbeitet werden. So das.
Ja also das.
Das ist glaube ich das ist glaube schon wieder so ein Kommunikationsfail äh erster Güteklasse. Warum reden sie erst mal dadrüber? Zweitens, was soll denn das? Also ich meine, haben also von Biontech liefern lassen, sollten sich das schon, weil das geht jetzt eh alles weg
Also es wird jetzt relativ schnell wieder in ein äh Nähe äh war alles nicht so gemeint. Äh natürlich bestellen wir mehr, weil jetzt wollen ja auch alle sich wieder impfen lassen, also zumindest die Busseimpfung holen.
Nee, es geht darum, sozusagen äh die Auslieferungen an die Ärzte und Impfzentren. Also ja, die wollen sie.
Sie wollen das halt anders verteilen. Das ist das finde ich auch in Ordnung, aber ob das jetzt eine große Diskussion wert ist, weiß ich gar nicht.
Nee, zumal äh ja gut ja halbe Dosis moderner äh so.
Sollte es auch tun und ich denke mal auch, dass ja je mehr verschiedene
Impfungen äh glaube ich äh umso äh besser die Wirkungen wahrscheinlich umso breiter äh vermutlich dann dann auch die die Wirkung. Also zumindest scheint's nicht schlechter zu sein und ja und,
Okay.
Auf jeden Fall das ist jetzt so meine persönliche Situation. Ähm
Vielleicht noch mal genauer drauf äh eingehen, was da jetzt auch so die Erkenntnislage ist, würde ich sagen. Schauen wir erst mal auf die Zahlen, weil das ist natürlich jetzt das große Thema. Wir haben also wieder steigende Inzidenzen,
und wir haben ja auch sehr viele andere steigende äh Kurven und so haben wir bisher immer noch äh dran und Haustiere.
Zahlen vom RKI in deine Risikotabelle. Ich bin ein bisschen ähm finde es grad selber jetzt ein bisschen.
Schade, dass ich ähm,
geschafft habe meine persönliche Impffortschrittsbetrachtung wieder ans Laufen zu bekommen. Ich musste das ja mal aussetzen, weil die beim Impf
einfach das Dateiformat äh unangekündigt und und dokumentiert vor allem geändert haben und ich dann bisher die Energie nicht aufgebracht habe, das anzupassen. Dann kam halt noch die Drittlimpfung mit dazu und äh von daher musste ich mir das nochmal neu machen, aber es.
Relativ wenig Auswertung der Impfsituation, die mir persönlich gefallen. Von daher muss ich das noch mal machen, aber bin einfach bisher noch nicht dazu gekommen.
Ja gut, was kann man sagen äh zu den zu den Zahlen jetzt. Ja, also so eine
Inzidenz Explosion hatten wir noch nie zuvor äh in der gesamten Pandemie nicht ähm ja wir sind jetzt,
Deutschland,
Weit sind wir jetzt auf einer Inzidenz von 390 nach publizierten Fällen und 360 nach Meldedatum.
Echt äh der Unterschied nochmal, also wir machen halt im Gegensatz zum RKI.
Auch noch Auswertungen, wie viel jetzt publiziert wurde und äh nach Meldedatum ähm sind halt die offiziellen Zahlen, aber die weichen dann halt ein bisschen.
Weil äh na ja, das Meldedatum dann immer ein bisschen zurückliegt und weil die sich im Nachgang dann quasi auch noch verändern, weil noch Meldungen äh äh nachkommen, während die nach Publikationsdatum.
Seit der Stichtag, so das, was täglich an Zahlen gemeldet wird, aber das halt dann entsprechend zusammengezählt und und und ausgewertet. Ja.
Und ja und wenn man dann auch noch in die einzelnen Bundesländer guckt, dann ist Sachsen
mal wieder ganz vorne grade mit einer Inzidenz von neunhundertvierundachtzig
nach Publikationsdatum und 790 nach nach Meldedatum. Also es ist halt auch krass, wie das jetzt im Moment gerade auseinanderläuft. Normalerweise sind die Zahlen
oft sehr eng beieinander, aber wenn da jetzt so eine Dynamik wie jetzt reinkommt ja, dann äh geht es halt
richtig, richtig ab und bei den auch R-Werten, die R-Werte.
Ja für für Deutschland liegen wir gerade bei 1,17. Das ist jetzt.
Super spektakulär, aber ähm ja äh solide Hoch und,
Das sind halt auch je nach Bundesland also wir haben halt auch Bundesländer.
Ähm die deutlich höher liegen ähm so in Brandenburg gerade haben wir pro Woche sechzig Prozent,
Zuwachs äh in den in den Zahlen in Sachsen irgendwie vierundvierzig Prozent ja und im im Bundesschnitt sind's halt immer noch dreißig Prozent
mehr Fälle jede Woche und ja heute waren's eben aktuell dreiundsechzigneunhundertvierundzwanzig.
Neue Infektionen so. Das ist äh ja
Das ist ähm mittlerweile fast jenseits von Gut und Böse, aber es aber nach oben ist äh leider noch einiges an Luft offen und es sieht auch
überhaupt nicht so aus, als wenn sich da grade irgendetwas stabilisieren würde
wobei wir auch den Effekt kennen, also zumindest in Tschechien, war es auch so, die Tschechien hatten sich ja auch irgendwann mal entschieden.
Im letzten Jahr, dass corona vorbei ist und dass man da jetzt nichts machen muss. Woraufhin sie auch dann so Tausender-Inzidenzen bekommen haben.
Aber klar ist auch, dass es äh da Grenzen gibt, dass es nicht nicht ewig in die Höhe gehen wird, weil erstens die Leute selber anfangen.
Aufzupassen und ihr Verhalten ändern, wenn sie sehen, was was passiert, dann hm.
Wird natürlich auch werden Maßnahmen ergriffen werden zwangsläufig von der Politik in dem Moment.
Wo ja jetzt die Krankenhäuser voll sind, muss halt äh was passieren, also ab einem bestimmten Punkt hat die Politik.
Einfach keine Wahl mehr als äh Lockdown und,
Meine Einschätzung hier auch auf Twitter geäußert habe, ist so grob. Na ja, die Hälfte der Bundesländer schätze ich, würzig irgendwie,
durchmogeln können ohne Lockdown bei der also in den nächsten vier bis sechs Wochen, so sage ich mal, wird
die Hälfte der Bundesländer sich irgendwie durchmogeln können aber die andere Hälfte so wird um äh harte Maßnahmen nicht herum,
bis hin zu einem totalen Lockdown äh kann das sein in einigen Ländern, wo wirklich wir wieder,
So äh den so Lockdown im Stile von ganz am Anfang äh der Pandemie, der auch funktioniert hat und frappierend ist aber auch.
Wie wenn man sich jetzt den den Graphen über die gesamte Zeit anguckt wie jetzt die erste Coronawelle im Vergleich dann nur noch so ein kleiner Blip äh ist
ja
so und wenn man sich das für einige Bundesländer anguckt dann hat man das Gefühl okay da hat Corona überhaupt erst jetzt angefangen. Da gab's bisher in den letzten zwei Jahren im Vergleich kaum was. Ja da gab's so ein ja
aber auch da äh zieht es dann äh jetzt jetzt gerade in die Höhe und die andere Sache, die,
noch so richtig krass
äh äh sind halt die Inzidenzen in äh ja bei den bei den Kindern, also vor allem in der Altersgruppe fünf bis 4zehn
Und wenn man da in einige Landkreise hinein hineinschaut, da haben wir bei
Kindern äh Inzidenzen äh also in dieser Altersgruppe so äh in.
Eine Handvoll Landkreise jetzt über dreitausend
und der Rekord, den ich da gefunden habe, der neue
Inzidenzrekord, gut, das hat wahrscheinlich vielleicht auch ein bisschen was mit Nachmeldungen oder so zu tun, liegt
aber bei ähm über viertausend, äh ich gucke gerade mal im Landkreis Oberspreewald-Lausitz äh ausgerechnet. Das ist zwar vielleicht irgendwo einen
auch einen Flug, wie gesagt, aber da sind die offiziellen Zahlen 4720 Fälle je 00.000
in den letzten sieben Tagen. Ähm das sind halt
4,7 Prozent der Kinder haben sich dort
in den letzten sieben Tagen ähm mit Corona infiziert, mindestens. Wenn wir jetzt davon ausgehen,
dass wir jetzt da auch noch eine dunkelste Fahrt vielleicht von Faktor zwei oder drei haben, weil es ein bisschen unklar ist. Dann.
Kann man sagen, dass wahrscheinlich grade in der letzten Woche äh sich dort äh ja zehn bis 15 Prozent aller Kinder mit Corona infiziert haben. Das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen.
Ja, das ist die Durchseuchung äh wo äh in den sozialen Medien viel drüber geredet wird. Ähm.
Hat man in dem Zusammenhang auch noch mal die Testzahlen nennen. Die sind natürlich rapide nach oben geschossen in den letzten Wochen. Wir hatten jetzt so viele Tests wie
fast noch nie also wir sind jetzt ungefähr bei 1,6 Millionen Tests, den äh Level hatten wir bisher nur,
genau vor einem Jahr genau in denselben beiden äh Kalenderwochen erreicht gehabt 2020.
Als eben uns auch die zweite Welle quasi erfasst hat. Das
ist jetzt eine schöne Parallele. Jetzt haben wir genauso viel Testung, allerdings ist die positiven Quote, also der Anteil der positiven Tests dabei spielt in einer ganz anderen Liga, hat mir also vor einem Jahr
7,1 und respektive 7,86ähProzent aller Tests, die positiv ausgefallen sind, aller PCR-Tests.
Sind es jetzt in der letzten Woche 5zehn ,neun und jetzt halt ähm,
also in der vorletzten Woche war es 5zehn ,neun Prozent und in der letzten Woche waren's siebzehn Komma.
Zwo 7 Prozent, was auch insgesamt die höchste positiven Quote ist, die wir je hatten und was können wir daraus schließen? Das bedeutet, wir erfassen derzeit.
Das Infektionsgeschehen noch nicht mal ansatzweise. Wir haben's nicht unter Kontrolle. Es wird nicht genug getestet, ähm um um überhaupt zu erfassen, was Phase ist und das bedeutet, dass die Dunkelziffer,
der tatsächlichen Infektionen,
tja, irgendwo so um Faktor zwei oder drei, denke ich mal, angesetzt werden muss, um eine Vorstellung davon zu bekommen, was jetzt tatsächlich passiert.
In der Größenordnung könnte das liegen, wobei das halt immer äh von
mit der Dunkelziffer ist es halt äh wirklich sehr äh kompliziert, weil die erstens regional sehr unterschiedlich sein kann. Dann
In den Altersgruppen sehr unterschiedlich sein kann. Also gerade Altersgruppe fünf bis vierzehn, wenn dort beispielsweise sämtliche Schüler äh zweimal die Woche durchgetestet werden, hat man natürlich
äh eine eine krasse Test-Coverage äh in dem Altersbereich. Das heißt ähm,
Dort könnte dann die Dunkelziffer wiederum niedriger ist.
Sein auf der anderen Seite sind dann die Inzidenzen natürlich so gewaltig hoch ähm dass wir glaube ich äh jetzt äh auch äh wieder gerade
in die Grenzen der Testkapazitäten ganz klar reinlaufen. Und.
Man muss dazu sagen, die Schüler, die regelmäßig getestet werden, werden ja nicht regelmäßig PCR getestet, sondern die werden regelmäßig mit Antigen-Tests getestet und äh bei den hohen Zahlen kommt natürlich jetzt auch die Sensitivität
der Tests dann wiederum ins äh Spiel und das ähm erfasst natürlich auch nicht alles, aber stimmt schon. Ähm.
Sind verschiedene Kräfte am Werk, ich sag's mal als anders, es gibt eine Dunkelziffer und das, was wir da jetzt grade messen, entspricht sicherlich nicht der Realität. Sondern,
Die Zahl ist höher. Ob das jetzt das Zweifache ist oder das Dreifache ist, spielt in dem Falle,
keine Rolle, weil selbst wenn dem nicht so wäre, wär's immer noch schlimm genug. Andererseits ähm können wir ja jetzt fast glaube ich auch nochmal so das Gedankenspiel mit der Herdenimmunität äh durchspielen, weil bei den Infektionszahlen, wenn das jetzt eine Weile anhält
dann rollt es halt dann auch wirklich durch die ganze Gesellschaft.
Ja, das ist das ist halt das
das Ding tatsächlich, wenn man das, wenn man das hochrechnet bei, sagen wir mal, bei den 3000er Inzidenzen
Plus dann Dunkelziffer und sagt OK wir liegt tatsächlich vielleicht irgendwo eher dann bei bei 500bis bis zehntausend, dann.
Man so zehn bis 20 Wochen ungefähr um äh die Bevölkerung zu durchseuchen. Wenn jetzt.
Die Inzidenz auf der Ebene bleiben würde, aber wenn sie halt jetzt noch weiter in die Höhe schießt, dass sie sich mit den ja aktuellen Wachstumsraten ähm,
so in die Höhe geht äh kann man auch innerhalb von vier bis sechs Wochen äh äh die komplette Bevölkerung oder zumindest eine bestimmte Altersgruppe äh durchseuchen.
Und äh ja ich habe auch mal überschlagen.
So was das den Bedeuten würde, jetzt für das Gesundheitssystem, beziehungsweise erst mal äh.
Was hast du fürs Gesundheitssystem? Bedeutet es ein bisschen bisschen schwieriger, aber äh so anhand der zu erwartenden Toten. Äh kann man das, glaube ich, ein bisschen abschätzen, äh weil
Sicherlich nicht ganz proportional das Hospitalisierung und Todesfälle so der Anteil, die schwanken, aber
im Großen und Ganzen je größer der Anteil der Todesfälle in einer Altersgruppe, umso höher auch ähm die Zahl der Hospitalisierungen.
Und äh schweren Fälle, so Größenordnungsmäßig, wie,
da gibt's halt noch noch äh Unterschiede und gerade bei Kindern ist es wahrscheinlich so, dass das halt äh Hospitalisierung äh dann ähm höher ist als jetzt die Zahl der
Todesfälle, die extrem gering ist. Das ist halt wenn man diese ganzen Alterskategorien,
betrachtet. Wenn man sich jetzt anguckt, was äh wenn's jetzt wenn wir's jetzt laufen lassen sozusagen deutschlandweit ähm.
Jetzt die verschiedenen Altersgruppen äh äh durchinfizieren, dann können wir in der Altersgruppe 5 bis 14 mit.
50 bis 200 toten Kindern äh rechnen äh durch durch covid. So ähm.
Dass äh ja äh das muss man halt
bewerten wollen. 14 hatten wir bisher, also 14 tote Kinder und das wird dann irgendwo auf 50 bis 200 hoch,
passiert es in der Altersgruppe 15 bis 34 ist das Potenzial äh Obergrenze ungefähr zu erwartende dreitausend Tote.
Zwischen fünfzehn und vierunddreißig. Bisher waren's zweihundertsechsundvierzig. Aber da in dieser Altersgruppe schon äh.
Ja auch eine ganze Menge geimpft sind, immer noch zu wenig, würden's wahrscheinlich in äh
eher auf irgendwas äh zwischen tausend und zweitausend Toten hinauslaufen. Am anderen Ende, wenn's jetzt die alten erfasst, reden wir.
Von bis zu 400.000 Toten über 80, die wir äh maximal erwarten können ohne Obergrenze liegt die,
Obergrenze sogar bei bis zu einer Million.
Haben wir denn überhaupt so viele?
Ja ja, wir haben äh äh was waren das? Äh habe ich mich da verrechnet? Mhm.
Also 80 plus Bevölkerung in Deutschland sind 5,6 Millionen.
Ja. Okay und davon äh okay, das kommt aber hin ungefähr zwei ja zwanzig Prozent äh davon äh wären's dann das passt. Äh.
Zwanzig Prozent, also jeder fünfte aus achtzig Plus.
Das waren sozusagen die äh das wären die Raten so an Ungeimpften, so wenn sich wenn sich alle infizieren in dieser Alters.
Also du du redest jetzt nur von den Ungeimpften, Achtzigjährigen? Nein. Du redest von allen Achtzigjährigen.
Ich rede von allen Achtzigjährigen.
Okay, aber zwanzig Prozent sind ja nicht vierhunderttausend dann.
Nein, das sind dann zehn Prozent. Also bei sozusagen aktuell äh ist äh ist die ähm sozusagen die Infektionssterbe äh Rate ungefähr äh äh zehn Prozent, ja?
Äh bei äh bei dem bei diesen neunzig Prozent jetzt achtzig, neunzig Prozent äh Impfstatus, den wir grade haben
so sterben 10 Prozent der Infizierten in der Altersgruppe. Aber wenn man das nach hoch durchrechnet, muss dann natürlich wieder die,
Dunkelziffer mit äh einberechnen, aber ähm ja.
Das sind so die die Größenordnungen, um um um die es.
Also mit anderen Worten, wenn es jetzt einfach ungehindert ohne weitere Maßnahmen so durchläuft.
Wird's richtig fett. So und da haben wir,
Toten zu rechnen und wir haben jetzt schon fast 100.000 Tote zu beklagen im Rahmen dieser Pandemie, an nachgewiesenen Todesfällen durch covid-19und das ist, wie Martin Findrich auf Twitter so schön feststellte, mehr als die gemeldete Infektionszahl
von der Volksrepublik China.
Und äh äh Drosten rechnet äh damit, dass äh wir ungefähr nochmal bei 100.000 Toten rauslaufen könnten jetzt in dieser Welle, wenn,
Ja, also 1hunderttausend weitere tote, äh nochmal, dass sich die Zahl der Toten verdoppeln könnte jetzt in dieser vierten äh Welle.
Ja ich meine wenig überraschend. Also wir werden jetzt allein in den nächsten Wochen, weil das ist ja jetzt alles vorbei, hat zumindest der Herr Wiela von vom RKI gesagt, der rechnet also jetzt mal mit 4hundert pro Tag.
Dass wir das auf jeden Fall erreichen werden. In zehn Tagen sind das halt.
Viertausend, ne, in drei Monaten sind das halt irgendwie mal locker 40.000 und wenn die Zahl sich jetzt noch weiter so beschleunigt, dann ist das alles nicht unrealistisch. Also es klingt nicht schön, aber es ist halt so.
Nee, also wir sehen, wie gesagt, vor allen Dingen sehen wir auch nicht nirgendwo, dass sich das jetzt gerade irgendwie stabilisieren würde. Ähm.
Sonst wird einfach alles nur schlimmer grade.
Sondern es es wächst halt mehr oder weniger ungebremst weiter und selbst wenn wir jetzt.
Sagen rechnerisch einen Rückgang, der R-Werte sehen würden, so.
Was wir nicht wirklich sehen.
Dann äh würde das wahrscheinlich daran liegen,
wir in die äh Limits äh beim Testen reinlaufen.
Die Testkapazität nicht mehr haben. Das heißt, selbst wenn wir jetzt äh ja einen Knick sehen würden im Anstieg, könnten wir dem noch nicht mal trauen.
Ja? Also wir müssten gut letztlich äh können wir uns im Moment fast nur noch an der positiven
Quote orientieren, ähm weil dann weil die Inzidenzen eben jetzt durch durch die ja durch die Limits beim Testen langsam gecappt werden.
Genau. Und wenn man's an der positiven Quote orientieren, stellen wir fest, die ist so hoch wie noch nie und die geht auch äh krass nach oben. Von daher tut sich da auch grad nicht so besonders viel Positives.
Ja, was aber vielleicht so eine Grundregel noch und da kommen wir dann äh äh gleich noch, wenn man jetzt die.
Aktuellen Inzidenzen, mit denen der vorherigen Wellen vergleichen will, kann man einen Faktor von 2 bis drei Ansätzen, also die um
das zwei bis dreifache reduzieren, was die Auswirkungen jetzt auf das Gesundheitssystem.
Angeht. Das heißt, während wir, ich sage mal, vorher vielleicht bei bei fünfhundert die äh.
Krankenhäuser dicht gelaufen sind,
angenommen in irgendeiner Gegend wird's jetzt irgendwo bei 1.000 bis 1.500 dieselbe
ähm ja äh den den selben Druck äh erreichen oder dieselbe Hospitalisierungs äh Inzidenz äh oder so gegenüber.
Den vorherigen Wellen, wobei das dann wiederum auch sehr stark abhängt, in welchen Altersgruppen äh das das gerade drin ist und.
Eben auch nicht zu erwarten ist, ist, dass wenn's jetzt bei den Jungen so in die in die Höhe schießt, wird das halt nicht bei den Jungen bleiben, sondern breitet sich dann natürlich in alle Altersgruppen äh aus.
So das ist das Ding und ich bin mir nicht
ganz klar sagen, wann das Virus sich jetzt durchgebrannt hat irgendwo in in einer äh Gegend. Ähm.
Ja werden wir sehen. So in der Vergangenheit gab's halt dann immer so Effekte gesagt wenn's denn dann hoch geht äh begrenzt sich der Anstieg.
Irgendwann von von selbst, weil die Leute halt anfangen aufzupassen oder weil das Virus vielleicht in der nächsten Umgebung dann tatsächlich niemanden mehr findet. Aber bis dahin ist es ist es noch weit.
Weithin glaube ich und das führt dann auch nur zu einem sagen wir mal vorübergehenden äh ähm Abbremsen des des Anstiegs und nicht zu einem Rückgang oder so unbedingt solche solche Effekte.
Ja
Die Politik äh überhaupt nichts unternimmt, kann man jetzt allerdings auch nicht äh sagen in Sachsen äh wurde es jetzt den Krematorien auch gestattet sonntags zu arbeiten. Insofern,
alles in Butter.
Ja düsterer Ausblick. Jetzt denk ich mal sollten wir mal eine Debatte äh aufgreifen die eine große Rolle gespielt hat in der Öffentlichkeit, nämlich die Sache mit den Impfdurchbrüchen. Da haben wir ja auch schon mal drüber.
Geredet generell, aber du hast ja jetzt auch nochmal die RKI-Zahlen von letzter Woche angeschaut oder von dieser Woche angeschaut ähm wo man halt aufgeschlüsselt bekommt, wie es denn jetzt eigentlich realistisch.
Aussieht wie das Verhältnis von Leuten, die sich geimpft haben, aussieht zu Leuten, die sich,
geimpft haben oder die nicht vollständig geimpft sind oder nicht doppelt geimpft sind mindestens.
Genau und da muss man vielleicht zwei Sichten ähm.
Vergleichen. So einmal.
Die Sicht der äh wie es so schön heißt, ja Hospitalisierungs äh oder so so was. Die Inzidenzen in den jeweiligen Gruppen, also unter den Geimpften und unter den
Ungeimpften ähm gerechnet jeweils auf die ja Größe der der Gruppe.
Oder also das ist die eine Sache, die halt eine Aussage darüber macht über das persönliche Risiko, das das Risiko des Einzelnen, wenn er geimpft ist,
oder nicht geimpft ist. Die andere Sicht ist halt äh dann die, wie viele wie viele.
Ja Ungeimpfte und wie viele Geimpfte denn jetzt ähm ja ähm.
Erkrankt sind, einen absoluten
Fällen beziehungsweise ähm sagen der Anteil der äh symptomatischen Fälle und äh wie viele Hospitalisiert werden mussten, intensiv sind und wie viel Versterben in den jeweiligen äh äh
Gruppen so, was dann wiederum mehr in Richtung äh ja äh.
Belastung des des Gesundheits äh Systems äh äh Auskünfte ermöglicht, wenn man nämlich dann äh dazu geht und noch die Impfquoten äh dazunimmt,
dann äh ja äh ist erstmal der der Schluss ähm.
Es ist jetzt nicht wirklich die Epidemie der äh Ungeimpf,
äh wie es so schön gesagt wurde, sondern es ist
unsere gemeinsame Epidemie. Jetzt ist es die Epidemie der Geimpften und der Ungeimpften so. Beide äh tragen
äh etwa in gleicher Weise Größenordnungsmäßig gerade zum
zur Verbreitung der der Infektion und zur Belastung des Gesundheitssystems bei, wobei natürlich äh siebzig Prozent
Geimpfte ich sage mal so viel Probleme machen wie zwanzig, dreißig Prozent ungeimpfte. Das ist so äh,
in etwa das Verhältnis. So kann man das äh ganz ganz grob äh zusammenfassen und äh das macht natürlich einen
erheblichen Unterschied oder die Impfquote macht halt schon einen erheblichen Unterschied für die Gesamtinzidenz in der Bevölkerung, weil natürlich sich das dann schneller ausbreitet und schneller wächst und
Da hatte ja der vorher dann noch offen paar einzelne Zahlen jetzt in den Altersgruppen äh eingehen. Da hatte ja der Dirk Pessler auch so eine schöne
Grafik gemacht, wo er mal geguckt hat. Korrelation, wie sieht es in den Bundesländern aus mit den.
Mit der Anzahl ungeimpfter und wo liegt dort die Inzidenz? Und da sieht man dann schon einen ganz guten äh Zusammenhang, äh dass.
Einfach im Prinzip je höher äh die.
Impfquote, umso niedriger die Inzidenz ganz grob. Ja, da gibt's gibt's dann
natürlich Abweichungen, so Sprünge nach nach oben und nach unten, aber generell ist dieser dieser Trend ganz klar zu sehen, so Sachsen, einfach mit.
Meisten Ungeimpften und Thüringen haben auch die höchsten.
Inzidenzen ganz klar und Bremen mit der höchsten,
Impfquote ja hat die niedrigsten Inzidenzen gerade insgesamt. Also insofern impfen hilft impfen wirkt.
Impfen ist gut.
Aber äh im Moment äh wird uns leider in diesem Jahr das Impfen eben nicht mehr wirklich helfen, sondern das wird sich dann erst im Januar irgendwann nieder.
Schlagen frühestens, äh wenn wenn wir jetzt ordentlich boostern und und impfen, aber ja für für dieses Jahr.
Kriegen wir uns da wie gesagt nicht nicht rausgebustert.
Mehr so und deswegen macht es jetzt auch keinen Sinn irgendwie so auf den Ungeimpften rumzuprügeln und sagen, wenn ihr euch jetzt alle impfen lasst, dann ist jetzt sofort alles äh vorbei. Nee, denn ich meine
sollten's trotzdem tun, weil wir dann vielleicht die Chance haben im Januar oder im im Februar dann,
aus der Katastrophe raus zu sein und es wird ganz ganz viele Menschenleben retten, aber das Kind ist äh im Grunde genommen jetzt erstmal in den in den Brunnen gefallen, dass wir jetzt äh.
In in in weiten Teilen um Lockdowns nicht umherkommen.
Reden wir es doch mal andersrum. Angenommen wir hätten jetzt 95 Prozent geimpft oder vielleicht sogar mal 100 Prozent, was natürlich jetzt überhaupt nicht realistisch
deswegen sage ich ja auch mal angenommen, ne? Also wenn man da jetzt also allein jetzt dieser Zahlenlogik folgen würde und sagen würde, okay, alles klar, unter den Bedingungen würde es auch bei diesen Geimpften,
noch zu Infektionen kommen, sofern man jetzt keine Maßnahmen,
hat oder sagen wir mal so wenig Maßnahmen wie wir eben derzeit auch haben.
Dann würde es ja immer noch ein Infektionsgeschehen geben.
Das Virus würde sich verbreiten, es würde sich nicht besonders schnell verbreiten. Also was wäre, ich möchte nur mal so darauf hinaus nochmal vom Gefühl her, was wäre dann anders? Also es würde sich nicht so schnell.
Ausbreiten.
Es würde vielleicht sich immer noch irgendwie exponentiell ausbreiten, aber so langsam, dass man's noch kontrollieren kann. Die Belastung der Krankenhäuser wäre signifikant niedriger
da können wir vielleicht auch mal auf Zahlen kommen, also als es ja immer nachgerechnet, das ist ungefähr so Faktor
je nach Altersgruppe, so Faktor drei bis vier ist ungefähr, ne, also deutlich weniger Belastung und natürlich äh sehr viel weniger Tote, weil das einfach im.
Da das Impfen am meisten schützt, so.
Also man könnte sogar sagen, ähm ich meine, die aktuellen Inzidenzen äh ist ja äh sagen wir mal, man guckt also Geimpfte.
Ungeimpfte an, Geimpfte stecken äh äh auch Geimpfte,
an und wenn man jetzt die Ungeimpften quasi rausnehmen würde,
dann äh wären die R-Werte alle äh unter äh eins, dann äh würden äh ja dann würde es würde würden die Inzidenzen sinken und die äh Infektion würde zum zum Stillstand.
Kommen, so dass es äh das das wäre zu erwarten, aber in der in der momentanen Mischung oder oder Gesamtsituationen.
Einfach äh ja wo eben die ähm Ungeimpften sagen auch ja mehr.
Verbreiten und eben auch Geimpfte anstecken. So ja,
wir eben dann deutlich über eins in der in der.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, wären jetzt alle geimpft. Und du sagst, dann wäre aber der R unter eins. Dann würde sich die Infektion totlaufen, dann wären wir die Pandemie zumindest erstmal vorübergehend erstmal wieder.
Und dem ist halt nicht so, ja? Ich denke in diesem Spruch Pandemie der Ungeimpften steckt nicht die Aussage drin.
Ausschließlich Ungeimpfte tragen derzeit dazu bei, dass das Geschehen voranschreitet, ja.
Sondern die Aussage ist eher weil es noch so viele Ungeimpfte gibt.
Kann sich hier einen R-Wert über eins ergeben und das lässt die ganze Sache halt rollen und das führt eben dazu, dass wir so hohe Inzidenzen haben und eben auch entsprechend viele Fälle haben. Und vor allem, dass noch hinten dran, das darf man nicht vergessen,
Es sterben ja jetzt nicht in der nächsten Zeit nur Leute.
Bekommen haben, sondern wir werden jetzt einfach sehr viele Todesfälle sehen von Leuten, die einen Autounfall hatten, Intensivstationen brauchen, keine finden.
Kinder, die irgendwelche Infektionskrankheiten haben, dringend äh irgendwie behandelt werden müssen, keinen finden. Leute, die einen Schlaganfall haben,
irgendwas irgendeinen Unfall. Die Intensivstationen sind voll, heißt,
Es gibt einfach keine Plätze und äh jetzt fahren die Ambulanzen halt mit den Leuten irgendwie von Krankenhaus zu Krankenhaus und versuchen irgendwie noch äh einen Platz zu finden, aber es ist halt einfach alles voll, weil eben die ganzen Überschusskapazitäten jetzt durch
Covid-Infizierte ähm bedeckt werden und das ist halt das sekundäre äh Problem. Ganz unabhängig davon, wie geschützt man es jetzt durch eine Impfung.
Überlastung ist das Problem.
Aber der der Punkt war, dass äh.
Glaube viele Leute dazu geneigt waren, so bei ähm aus Pandemie der äh Ungeimpften äh zu schließen, dass sie,
Persönlich jetzt nicht so bedroht sind äh oder dass sie ja ich sage mal mehr oder weniger komplett geschützt sind oder sehr weitgehend geschützt sind. Und das mag.
So in den ersten Monaten, sage ich mal, zwei, drei Monaten nach der Impfung
auch der Fall sein, aber bei den meisten Leuten äh ist das jetzt glaube ich so langsam sechs Monate her oder oder länger, dass sie geimpft worden sind und
da sehen wir eben beim Schnitt um das jetzt mal für die Altersgruppe auch mal äh,
zählen beziehungsweise das Problem ist natürlich, dass wir bei den Impfungen äh die Erfassung der Altersgruppen, dass es da nur drei Altersgruppen gibt, 12 bis 17 gerade, 18 bis 59 und 60 Jahre und älter, was natürlich jetzt nicht zu den anderen äh Zahlen
äh äh wieder wieder passt unbedingt, aber so war's halt schon krass ist äh hier jetzt in dem RKI-Bericht, Datenstand sechzehnter Elfter.
Äh Impfdurchbrüche KW 2undvierzig bis fünfundvierzig gab's halt
insgesamt 50.000 symptomatische covid-Fälle so.
Wobei das nur die Fälle sind, sind das sind nicht alle Fälle, sondern nur die Fälle für die Informationen vorliegen, weil irgendwie 20, 30 Prozent der Fälle, äh die übermittelt werden, ohne Impfstatus
übermittelt werden so. Aber,
Von den fünfzigtausend, äh die dort aufgezählt sind, waren dreißig,
vollständig geimpft. So, also 60 Prozent der symptomatischen,
Covid-Fälle äh sind vollständig geimpf.
Ähm vor den Hospitalisierten.
Covid-neunzehn Fällen, das waren in dem Fall 7000. So sind dreitausend.
150, also rund 45 Prozent sind äh
Durchbrüche auf den Intensivstationen ist es ein bisschen besser, das Feld ist ungefähr 1 zu3, also
vier oder ja vierhundertsechs von tausendvierundsiebzig Fällen also siebenunddreißig Komma acht Prozent und.
Bei den Verstorbenen äh waren 514 von 2dreiund2 äh Verstorbenen,
geimpft, also 42 Prozent der Verstorbenen waren geimpft.
So. Das sind halt äh gerade in etwa die Zahlen. Das klingt dann natürlich jetzt.
Ein bisschen schlimmer, wiederum als es ist, weil ja äh wiederum die Mehrheit tatsächlich geimpft,
ist. Äh so, aber was das sagen jetzt persönliche Risiko.
Angeht ähm kann man sagen oder was auch die Belastung äh vorhin hatten, jetzt das Gesundheitswesens angeht, tragen halt Geimpfte und Ungeimpfte. Ähm in etwa,
im gleichen Maße äh äh dazu bei mit ich sage mal ein bisschen mehr noch bei den bei den Ungeimpften, wie gesagt vierzig, vierzig Prozent kann man sagen, round about ähm.
Gerade sind äh Geimpfte und 60 Prozent sind ungeimpft. Die.
Müssen wir aber gleich hinterher schieben, ja? Nochmal was du eben
so angedeutet hast. Das ist extrem wichtig jetzt diese Zahlen richtig zu kontexualisieren, weil das ist natürlich jetzt hier auch so ein Mantra, was von diesen ganzen äh Schwoblheinis
auch schnell wieder auf den Tisch gebracht wird. Hier siehst du, Impfung bringt ja überhaupt nichts, weil so und so viel Prozent, ne? Dann kommst du dann hier schon bei diesen Fällen ja 6061 Prozent der symptomatischen Fälle äh
alle geimpft, das hilft ja alles gar nix. Das sagt diese Zahl nicht aus. Warum nicht? Weil man sie nicht zueinander in Relation stellen muss, so, sondern das ist halt
quasi
im Vergleich zu sehen zu der Zahl von Leuten, die geimpft sind oder die nicht geimpft sind und wie du eben schon angedeutet hast, dadurch, dass wir jetzt hier im Prinzip so eine zweiDrittel, ein Drittel Verhältnis haben
reduziert sich dann eben auch dieser Anteil entsprechend. Ähm,
Das ist eben das Wichtigste, das heißt letzten Endes muss man auch hier auf die Inzidenz schauen und gucken, okay, wie verhält sich das zur Gesamtbevölkerung? Was ist der Anteil der Betroffenen
die geimpft sind eben auf die Gesamtbevölkerung gerechnet und da ist ja dann der Unterschied schon schon deutlicher zu sehen.
Äh genau, also bei den immer symptomatischen Fällen äh kann man sagen, äh ist es äh ungefähr ist die die Inzidenz.
Unter den Ungeimpften dreimal so hoch
je nach Altersgruppe natürlich auch wenn man jetzt mal sechzig plus rausgreifen, sind eben äh in in 60 Plus. Da haben wir so viele ungeimpfte Symptomatisch äh wie äh geimpfte und
jetzt der Hospitalisierung äh ist das Verhältnis sogar nochmal äh deutlich größer. Da ist es.
Ungefähr das fünffache, also ähm sagen fünfmal.
Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit
ins Krankenhaus zu kommen äh ist als Ungeimpfter 60 Plus 5mal so hoch äh rund wie
wenn man geimpft ist ja. Aber es sind halt nicht die fünfundneunzig,
oder 98 Prozent Schutz, die man,
jetzt kurz nach der Impfung, also drei, vier Wochen nach der Impfung hat, sondern da sieht man jetzt eben tatsächlich.
Das wissen wir jetzt, dass halt eigentlich der der der hohe Schutz äh der unglaublich hohe Schutz.
Tatsächlich nur, ich sage mal, drei, vier, fünf Monate ungefähr.
Anhält. Es ist sehr sehr individuell.
Wohlgemerkt nach der Zweitimpfung.
So und jetzt kommt die Drittimpfung und da gibt's jetzt kann man nicht gleich dieselbe Aussage draus schlussfolgern. Das kann so sein wissen wir ja.
Werden wir sehen. Aber bisher deutet äh deuten die Zahlen ja eher auf etwas anderes hin, nämlich dass die dritte Impfung quasi der eigentliche.
Vorläufige Abschluss dieser Impfserie ist und man dann eben den höchsten Schutz äh erzielen kann und es sehr wohl sein kann.
Dass die Zahlen halt in vier Monaten, fünf, sechs Monaten ab dieser Booster-Impfung sich ganz anders darstellen.
Es jetzt die Auswirkungen der Zweitimpfung sich äh darstellt.
Also es es könnte tatsächlich seine Erfahrung machen wir jetzt, dass halt.
Sagen man im Grunde genommen drei Dosen
braucht. Ich meine, das haben wir ja bei anderen Impfungen kennen wir das ja auch, dass man dann erst eine Impfung macht und dann einen Monat später noch eine äh und dann noch einen Jahr später.
Noch eine und mit so einer dreifach Serie man dann unter Umständen ja eine lebenslange oder Jahrzehnte lange Immunisierung hat. Ob das hier auch der Fall sein wird
Wissen wir noch nicht, aber was wir auf jeden Fall wissen, ist, dass die dritte Dosis äh nochmal richtig
richtig einen Schub gibt. Also da sind dann ist dann von Faktoren, weiß ich nicht, zwanzig bis vierzigfache Verbesserung äh des des des Schutzes oder so sind, sind möglich.
Absolut, also es gab ja bisher die Zahlen aus Israel, weil die ja natürlich mit der Busterei ähm als erstes angefangen haben. Ähm mittlerweile gibt's wohl auch eine Studie aus UK.
Äh ähnliche Zahlen liefert, also im Prinzip äh das bestätigt, was man aus Israel äh kennt. Also.
Fast äh dasselbe äh Ergebnisse ähm.
Erkranken rund sieben mal seltener an symptomatischen covid als solche, die nur zwei Dosen bekommen haben.
Sieben. Also wir hatten in Israel auch Ähnliches gesehen von von sieben bis zehn äh Alter äh gestaffelt et cetera und das ja das ist sagen wir mal das
Das entscheidenste Argument, warum man jetzt eben, wenn man jetzt eh schon zwei Impfdosen erhalten hat, auch möglichst zügig jetzt hier eine Dritte bekommen sollte. Ich halte diese sechs Monate für die falsche Entscheidung, mache das mal früher, weil nach
vier Monaten zeigt sich halt einfach schon, dass der Impfschutz nicht mehr so hoch ist.
Ja und äh wenn man das einfach mal hochrechnet, wenn man sagt jetzt äh ja bei im Moment der der Hospitalis
Schutz bei jetzt zweifach.
Geimpften oder so wie's jetzt bei uns ist im im Schnitt. Äh wenn das jetzt Faktor fünf
ist und dann noch mal Faktor sieben äh oben drauf kommt, kommt man halt auf die ja Faktor dreißig bis bis vierzig oder so, äh die man dann.
Drei Impfungen besser geschützt ist äh als ein Ungeimpfter so und das ist dann schon mal ja. Also wenn dem so wäre und das sieht man auch an
Israel so, dann hat halt auch bei einer ja bei einer ausreichend hohen Impfquote des Virus einfach keine Chance mehr. Also wir wir
Könnten's weggeimpft und weggebustert äh kriegen, wenn wir jetzt reinhauen, aber äh
Das wird halt zwei, drei Monate dauern. Wir hätten eigentlich vor zwei Monaten mit dem Boostern äh beginnen müssen oder vor drei Monaten äh wie Israel damit äh ja äh uns das
erspart geblieben wäre, was.
Alles die ganze Zeit immer nur so machen müssen wie Israel. Hätte hätte hätte vollkommen gereicht so also einfach mach einfach nur genau das was Israel macht und dann dann passt das schon.
Na ja gut, also wenn das jetzt nicht die Pandemie der Ungeimpften ist, wie nennen wir die Pandemie denn derzeit äh.
Ja
Also also ich hatte äh da so einen einen Bild äh gefunden äh für wo ich gesagt habe also im Grunde genommen sitzen jetzt äh Geimpfte und Ungeimpfte.
In einem Boot, die Geimpften äh sitzen halt nicht so weit am Rand äh sondern die sitzen halt ein bisschen in der Mitte, sodass die, wenn's stürmisch wird, halt nicht so schnell äh über Bord äh äh
gespült werden aber wenn das Boot voll läuft so es ist halt egal.
So ob wir geimpft oder ungeimpft sind dann erwischt es uns alle.
Äh so in etwa ähm würde ich die Situation im Moment charakterisieren.
Und äh ja und wie gesagt.
So äh ungeimpfte tragen überproportional äh gerade bei äh und sorgen auch dafür, dass der R-Wert äh über eins äh ist, aber ähm.
So auch die Geimpften so verbreiten äh die Infektion ähm liegen in Krankenhäusern, liegen auf Intensivstationen und sterben, ja.
Aber die sitzen nicht nur an der an der Seite, sondern manche von denen wackeln halt auch noch am Boot.
Okay.
Sich halt jetzt die Frage äh wie voll ist unser Boot jetzt schon voll gelaufen? Ist das Boot quasi halb voll oder halbleer?
Da dreht sich der Optimismus mal komplett um.
Das äh können wir jetzt glaube ich nicht beurteilen.
Ja na ja nee im also das das Boot äh ist gerade irgendwie voll am Absaufen. So kann man kann man äh sagen und äh ja ohne ich sage mal jetzt.
Also das Boot ist halb voll.
Ja, das Boot ist schon ist bereits halbvoll gelaufen und äh ja, droht halt zu sinken so und
Ähm ja gut, womit man jetzt auch schon begonnen hat, ist mit der Verlegung dann von äh
Leuten aus bestimmten Bereichen, wo dann die Kliniken jetzt.
Voll sind, also gibt's ja auch. Jetzt irgendwie hat man sich irgendwie dieses Kleeblattschema ausgedacht, wo.
Gab's glaube ich schon vorher. Das ist nichts Neues. Mhm.
Ja ja aber das kommt jetzt quasi zum Einsatz.
Vielleicht für die Leute, die nicht das das nicht kennen, also die Bundesrepublik Deutschland ist in so fünf äh Zonen ähm aufgeteilt, also wo verschiedene Bundesländer zusammengeschlossen sind.
Ähm da weiß ich grad auswendig, nicht so ganz. Also ich äh wie wer hängt da mit wem zusammen?
Ähm ja hängen halt räumlich zusammen. Es sind halt fünf äh äh ja fünf Zonen, fünfblättriges Kleeblatt, ha ha.
Ja viel Glück.
Braucht man da auch.
Äh
Genau, das heißt überstellt, also in dem Moment, wo quasi ein Krankenhaus voll ist, dann kann man auch noch in Krankenhäuser in Bundesländer äh auslagern, also kann man Patienten auslagern in Krankenhäuser.
Die in Bundesländern sind, die zum selben Klemmblatt gehören, aber auch das funktioniert eben nicht mehr, also in Bayern wird jetzt teilweise auch schon mal nach Italien ausgeflogen äh et cetera,
P. Also wir haben jetzt eigentlich diese Triage-Situation auch schon langsam erreicht, dass halt einfach vor Ort äh entschlossen werden muss, wem wird jetzt überhaupt noch geholfen, weil halt nicht allen geholfen werden kann.
Ja, also ganz normal, ich hab's jetzt, ich hab's jetzt gerade nochmal vor mir, das, des, das Kleeblatt äh können wir dann auch noch mal so sagen. Also ein Blatt ist Bayern, ist ein Blatt für sich genommen.
Sein eigenes Blatt. Okay, ist wie im.
Ein eigenes Blatt und Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Ist auch sein eigenes Blatt. Klar, da sind die Bundesländer mit, ich glaube 16 und 12 Millionen Einwohnern oder so, also.
Ähm und dann gibt's das Kleeblatt Südwest, das ist seit Hessen, Rheinland-Pfalz, Saarland und Baden-Württemberg und dann gibt's das Kleeland
Ost mit Berlin, Brandenburg, Sachsen, Thüringen und Sachsen-Anhalt
dann gibt's das Kleeblatt Nord mit Bremen, Niedersachsen, Hamburg, Schleswig-Holstein und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, so das sind irgendwie hier die,
sagen die Dinge und da gibt's dann eben entsprechende Leitstellen auch und dann wird halt geguckt, dass man dann dort halt irgendwie.
Auch dann zwischen.
Dem Kleeblatt äh Ost mit zusammen mit Sachsen und Thüringen. Na dann gute Nacht.
Hurra!
Aber äh ja.
Wir leben noch.
Ja ja, nee und äh und die andere Sache
ist das natürlich gucken muss, äh dass man, wenn man jetzt dann Verlegungen macht, die so frühzeitig wie möglich macht, möglichst bevor die Leute noch nicht intensiv sind, weil Verlegung von Intensivpatienten
ist halt äh kompletter Irrsinn. Also wenn man
Das weiß, wenn Intensivpatienten verlegt werden müssen. Da ist irgendwie ein zwölf-köpfiges Team mit Vorbereitung äh beschäftigt und äh fliegt
dann äh äh mit und äh das ist das ist also das ist absoluter
Wahnsinn so und dann müsste halt Flugzeuge und alles irgendwie vorher und nachher desinfiziert werden und äh ja. Das äh Plus natürlich für die Patienten ist das dann auch nicht gerade.
Gut so insofern versucht man halt jetzt ähm die Patienten halt solange sie noch nicht
intensivpflichtig sind äh möglichst zu verlegen. Das ist jedenfalls die Idee oder der Appell, dass das passieren sollte. Das andere Problem
sind eben auch Schilderungen äh ja ähm was passiert eigentlich, wenn die Kliniken voll sind
Ähm so, dann ist halt auch nicht so, dass die jetzt dann sagen, nee, wir sind wir sind jetzt voll. Wir lassen dich jetzt einfach sterben, sondern dann tun die natürlich auch das das
Möglichste äh so, was dann aber auch noch mal zu einer krassen.
Überlastungssituation äh für das Personal führt und insgesamt natürlich die Qualität der Pflege und Betreuung sinkt.
Ich hatte, als ich mir mal die Grafen auch über sagen den die die ja die.
Ähm die CFR, also die Fallsterblichkeit äh über die Zeit angeguckt habe, so war halt auch bemerkenswert, dass in Hochinzidenz
Phasen halt auch die Fallsterblichkeit höher zu sein scheint. Das können Zahlen Artefakte sein, aber ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen, dass einfach in.
Den extrem niedrig Inzidenzphasen waren eben auch die Sterbe also die Falschsterblichkeit deutlich geringer als eben in den Hochinzidenzphasen. Ja.
Und äh generell, ich weiß nicht, ob wir auf das Kapitel Pflege jetzt äh äh grade kommen sollten, aber warum nicht? Wir sind wir sind jetzt glaube ich glaube ich gerade irgendwie dabei.
Und da sehen wir zum einen, dass es äh aktuell auch viel weniger Intensivbetten gibt als in den
letzten Phasen, zumindest was die Meldung angeht, wobei auch gesagt wird, teilweise na ja äh
in den letzten Phasen wurden halt teilweise mehr Betten gemeldet als wirklich hätten belegten
werden können, weil die Kliniken dafür auch bezahlt wurden äh sind und dass man da jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen restriktiver vorgeht, aber wir hatten tatsächlich
auch einen nennenswerten Personaltrain
in der Pflege, also es sind einfach auch weniger Leute da im Moment und die Leute, äh die da sind, haben.
Gerade so richtig die Schnauze voll. Also ähm ja äh aus äh irgendwie aus aus verschiedensten,
Gründen so, weil erstens äh ja.
Die Situation war vorher schon scheiße und hat sich äh nicht verbessert.
Und ich habe eine eine also eine,
Gute Freundin äh von mir äh so die in äh Nordrhein-Westfalen äh in der äh
Pflege arbeitet auf einer Akut-Suchtstation
wo es dann halt nochmal besonders krass ist natürlich, weil man's dort dann auch mit Leuten,
äh zu tun hat, die dann äh teilweise mit 4 bis7 Promille angeliefert,
äh werden oder ich sage mal andere psychische Probleme haben und wenn du den Leuten dann irgendwie auch noch dann weismachen musst
äh dass sie jetzt nicht ohne Maske über den Gang äh gehen dürfen oder so. Das das hat noch mal ja da hat man noch mal äh ganz ganz
andere äh Probleme an der Stelle. Plus das äh halt
wenn dort ein Infizierter ist, dann können die den natürlich auch nicht einfach in irgendein normales Krankenhaus verschieben, sondern haben da eine extra Pflegestation jetzt äh für äh dann äh ja, ich sage mal psychisch.
Kranke, die äh Covid-Infiziert äh sind, die halt dann noch mal massiv Personal abziehen für die Pflege,
von den äh anderen, sodass die Stationen da teilweise zusammen äh gelegt haben und äh ja, also das ist irre Plus
natürlich fast den gesamten Dienst äh so mit Maske äh äh rumlaufen äh zu müssen. Das.
Ja, macht's auch nicht, auch nicht toll und dann natürlich körperlich schwere Arbeit äh zum Teil verrichten zu müssen äh somit mit äh Maske. Das ist das ist schon die absolute Hölle.
Plus so ein Ding äh äh was ich nicht wusste, auf das ich aufmerksam geworden bin, wo.
Ich ich auch dachte, das kann ja wohl nicht wahr sein. Ähm.
Und zwar ist es so, dass es seit einigen Jahren in vielen Kliniken ähm.
Vereinbarungen gibt, dass wenn jetzt kurzfristige Dienstplanänderungen stattfinden, also wenn man jetzt einspringen muss, weil.
Wie auch immer ähm das ist dafür eine Prämie gibt. Wenn
jemand einspringt, je nachdem, ob das irgendwie nachts oder am Wochenende oder wie auch immer ist. So äh ist das je nach Bundesland und Klinik und so kann das halt
äh ganz anders sein, aber gibt's dann so Beträge zwischen, weiß ich nicht, äh also entweder gibt's dann einen höheren Stundensatz dafür oder es gibt so hundert, hundertfünfzig, zweihundert, dreihundert Euro fürs Einspringen
extra, wenn man das das jetzt macht. Jetzt war dort äh bei denen aber äh der Fall äh,
dass kein Mensch davon wusste, dass es eigentlich diese Prämienregelung gibt und diese Prämien auch nicht ausgezahlt wurden.
Dafür. Bis dann irgendjemand, der dann irgendwie aus anderen Gründen äh jetzt gefeuert äh äh
wurde äh äh daraufhin äh die Klinik verklagt hat äh äh auf Auszahlung halt dieser ganzen Prämien. Äh und Recht bekommen hat.
Ähm wo man jetzt denken würde, ah super
Jetzt haben dann irgendwie alle anderen auch ihre Prämien gekriegt. Nee, was die Klinik dann gemacht hat, ist äh allen ein Schreiben vorgelegt, wo dann drin stand hier und im Übrigen kriegt ihr jetzt fünfhundert Euro äh äh
Prämie äh äh so müsst ihr nur irgendwie hier unterschreiben, dann kriegt ihr irgendwie 5hundert Euro, was halt in dem Blatt mit drin stand war, dass halt mit den Zahlungen von den 5hundert Euro sämtliche eventuellen Prämien für
irgendwie einspringen des Dienstes aus der Vergangenheit damit erledigt.
Och.
Teilweise in die Tausende hätten gehen können und die Leute dachten, ach wunderschön, das ist jetzt also 500 Euro Corona-Prämie, super,
was sie halt gar nicht wussten ist, dass sie damit möglicherweise in Anspruch irgendwie auf tausende
von Euro äh äh gleichzeitig weggezeichnet haben und das ist gar nicht die Corona-Prämie wahr. Ja und die ist gegen äh äh sondern irgendwie um ihnen Ansprüche abzukaufen, ja. So ähm Arschloch mäßig äh geht es halt in der Pflege teilweise zu.
Ja und wegen vielleicht auch hier äh das vielleicht falls Pflegekräfte hier mal zuhören äh.
Sich äh äh vielleicht mal informieren sollten, wie das denn eigentlich in ihrer Klinik äh laufen sollte, wenn sie denn dann kurzfristig einspringen für irgendwelche Pflegedienste.
Hardcore. Ja also das ist äh es ist kein Spaß und ähm ich.
Weiß auch gar nicht mehr, was da was man was man dazu sagen soll. Ich meine, dafür muss man sich halt einfach nur noch schämen. Das äh äh dass man so in so einem System äh lebt, in dem halt einfach.
All die Berufe, die die wir so als essentiell kennengelernt haben in den letzten zwei Jahren und das ist in in so einer Pandemie natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht der essenziellste Dienst von allen.
Ähm ja, dass es einfach nach wie vor.
Normal zu sein scheint, dass man äh an der Stelle einfach keinerlei Bereitschaft zeigt, das auszugleichen. Also ich bin ohnehin sehr unzufrieden, wie das mit den Krankenhäusern aufgestellt ist. Ich bin.
Generell kein Freund davon, Krankenhäuser privat zu führen. Ja, also das äh.
Ist einfach keine gute Idee.
Ja also wie gesagt das das lass uns in in dieses äh äh Rabbit Foul äh jetzt nicht.
Nö, das müssen wir jetzt nicht ausführlich diskutieren, aber das das das kommt ja alles noch mit dazu. Ja, dass das sozusagen diese dieser Sparzwang äh alles diktiert.
Und dabei aber einfach ähm über Leute hinweg geht, die die da einfach mit Herzblut dabei sind, die einen Beruf haben.
Den ich persönlich nicht ausfüllen könnte.
Ja, also es werde ich einfach nicht dazu in in in der Lage umso dankbarer bin ich dafür, dass es Leute tun, umso erstaunter bin ich dann auch aus meiner ganz persönlichen Perspektive heraus, dass es Leute gibt,
das halt nicht nur machen, sondern dieses auch mit mit Passion machen, mit einer Verantwortung machen und die ja dann auch so in so einer mentalen Zwickmühle auch immer sind.
Ja, so dieses ja, ich ich könnte ja auch streiken, um meine Rechte durchzusetzen, ja.
Wo dann halt alle sofort wissen, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie auf der Intensivstation streiken, dann sterben halt alle meine Patienten.
So und ist deswegen dann halt auch nicht tun. Wo ist dann eben an der Stelle der Ausgleich?
Ja? Klar, Mülltonnen, die rumstehen und eine Woche lang nicht äh gelehrt werden, da hast du mehr Ratten und es stinkt und so weiter und das ist dann auch unangenehm. Aber davon geht die Welt nicht unter. Aber da geht die Welt halt den ganzen Tag über unter.
Und das ist irgendwie alles äh überhaupt nicht fein. Na gut, ich will das jetzt auch gar nicht weiter vertiefen, aber ich denke, das ist schon etwas, was man mal im Blick halten muss und äh ich habe ehrlich gesagt relativ wenig Hoffnung,
da viel äh ändern wird, aber ich wäre trotzdem sehr dafür, dass sich da äh was ändert. Gut, lass uns ähm in Themen noch.
Weiterkommen und zum Ende kommen.
Was wir noch äh erwähnen sollten, ist ja, dass jetzt die äh Impfung von Kindern äh von fünf bis 11 Jahren auch
quasi Ante Porters ist, also die äh EMA soll angeblich in vier Tagen, heute ist der zwanzigste
November 21. Es geht rum, dass irgendwo so 24. bis 26. in dem Zeitraum die MA,
da einen entsprechenden Beschluss fällt, dass eben die Impfung zugelassen ist. Das bezieht sich dann erst mal auf Biontech. Ähm.
Es ist wohl so, dass erwartungsgemäß hier eine sehr viel niedrigere Dosierung gewählt wird für Kinder.
Ähm und dass das wohl auch verbunden ist mit einer anderen.
Abmischung. Wobei ich das jetzt nicht benennen kann. Also das, was quasi da an Violen geliefert wird in die Impfzentren, zu den Ärzten, zu den Kinderärzten ähm
enthält eine andere Abmischung, also der eigentliche Impfstoff ist derselbe, aber da gehören ja noch ein paar andere Dinge dazu. Warum das so ist et cetera, weiß ich nicht. Auf jeden Fall
Ist das.
Ist das jetzt so und äh man geht wohl davon aus, dass ein EU-weiter Rollout gegen den 2.12., also kurz vor Weihnachten, erfolgen kann.
Fragt man sich natürlich so, aha, okay, wieso dauert das so lange?
Ähm na ja, das hat dann halt wieder was mit zu tun, dass es erst mal EU-weit ist und dass dann eben diese speziellen Violen genommen werden äh et cetera. Die müssen ja auch erst mal hergestellt, bereitgestellt werden. Stecke ich nicht drin. Nehme ich jetzt erst mal so hin. Es ist nur so,
ja nicht so, dass jetzt noch niemand Kinder geimpft hätte, sondern diese ganze Off-Label im Verein, die hat ja auch stattgefunden. Da ist also auch schon von Ärzten Kinderärzten.
Vermutlich primär oder ausschließlich sogar auch ähm.
Mit einer niedrigeren Dosis bereits schon geimpft worden, nur dass eben das nicht als offizielle Impfung so anerkannt wird, ne, nicht dokumentiert wird. Ähm das heißt, rein theoretisch könnte es auch.
Dieser Zulassung mit dem vorhandenen Biontech-Impfstoff auch schon offizielle Kinderimpfungen geben.
Das ist so mein Verständnis der Situation. Wird sich äh zeigen.
Ja, wobei man auch sagen kann, dass die Älteren von der Impfung der Kinder mehr profitieren werden äh äh wahrscheinlich als die Kinder selbst.
Äh so, die natürlich auch profitieren werden, je nach je nach Alter. Ähm so ähm
aber äh gerade beispielsweise im im Alter von null bis vier, äh sage ich mal, konnte ich jetzt äh was die Todesfälle zum Beispiel betrifft
nicht wirklich jetzt 'nen Unterschied finden also kein Zusammenhang mit den Inzidenzen.
Während's bei fünf bis vierzehn, wie gesagt, schon äh äh man es schon statistisch äh sieht, also durch also in der Alters äh Gruppe könnte Impfen äh halt äh ja fünfzig bis hundertfünfzig äh äh.
Kinder lieben, retten äh jetzt. Ja. So.
Aber die Impfung dieser äh Kinder äh würde wahrscheinlich zigtausend Älteren das Leben retten.
Ja dann ähm gab's ja noch Neues aus Schwobbelstan.
Gibt's jetzt irgendwie ein neues Wundermittel. Ich muss zugeben, mir ist an mir ist die Diskussion äh erstmal eine Weile vorbeigegangen, was.
Immer ganz froh stimmt, wenn ich so Schwungbelkram gar nicht so schnell mitbekomme. Das zeigt mir, dass meine äh.
Meine Wahl meiner Kanäle irgendwie äh passt, aber.
Irgendwie gibt's halt jetzt äh in diesen Kreisen die Vorstellung, dass so ein Pferdeentwurmungsmittel namens ever Meckthinan jetzt irgendwie die geile
die geile neue Sache wäre, um irgendwie gegen covid zu helfen. Ich verstehe gar nicht, was was die überhaupt so fürn,
für einen Film damit fahren, also auf der einen Seite äh gibt's das alles nicht und ist die Impfung ganz böse, ja, obwohl das wirklich das einzige ist, was nachweislich hilft.
Stattdessen feiern sie aber irgendwelche komischen Wundermittel, die dann doch gegen die Krankheit helfen, die es ja eigentlich gar nicht gibt.
Na ja, ja, äh gut, äh äh das äh sozusagen die innere Logik und äh Konsistenz äh
Ist eine andere Geschichte, aber äh so ja ich hatte das auch irgendwie so die als als Randphänomen irgendwie abgetan und es gab halt auch schon,
artikel, ich glaub vor einem halben Jahr irgendwie OK ist jetzt das neue Hydroxy Chloroquin
ähm so und äh ja habe mir als als äh gerade Entwurmungsmittel dann auf Twitter trendete vor ein paar Tagen. Äh so habe ich mich dann mal etwas genauer damit
auseinandergesetzt, was denn jetzt die Wissenschaft so sagt.
Besondere, weil es halt schon eine ganze Menge seriöse Studien auch.
Und äh ja und da wollte ich wollte ich dann einfach mal gucken äh weil eigentlich.
Also das Abtun als Entwurmungsmittel fand ich jetzt erst mal nicht besonders hilfreich und als Pferdemedizin, weil dann natürlich,
ich sage mal von der sag mal anderen Seite äh dann äh das valide Argument kommt Moment mal
Aber das es gibt auch eine ganze Reihe von Indikationen äh für
Behandlung von Menschen äh so ist es auch zugelassen. Also insofern ja sage ich halt jetzt
auch nicht. Irgendwie keine Ahnung. Großteil der Antibiotika wird irgendwie an Pferde und und,
Kühe äh verabreicht und da reden wir jetzt auch nicht. Wer Antibiotika irgendwie von äh ja äh von Pferde und und und Kuhmedizin. Insofern.
Ich das halt äh
Ja, nicht nicht wirklich hilfreich und auch tatsächlich völlig unerheblich auch für die Frage, ob's jetzt hilft oder nicht. Ja so das ist irgendwie, weiß ich nicht. Das das war mir also diese mag sein, dass es irgendwie vielleicht in einer ganzen Reihe von
Leuten vielleicht hilft, das irgendwie so abzutun, aber äh ja ähm ich glaube, das das kann halt auch äh nach hinten
losgehen und deswegen wollen wir mal gucken, was denn so jetzt die Wissenschaft eigentlich dazu sagt und was das RKI dazu sagt und RKI sagt
äh ganz kurz. Gut, der Evidenzgrad für einen Nutzen ist niedrig. Ja, aber nicht null,
würde ich jetzt dazu sagen äh so und man wartet auf bessere Studien. So, dann gibt's halt so eine recht bekannte.
Und umstrittene Metastudienseite äh ja unter anderem 10019 Evermedien.
Kommen zum Beispiel wo sie halt alle möglichen Studien auflisten und dann äh dort eben Statistiken rausholen und wenn man auf die Seite guckt.
Äh sieht es aus so äh wow super krass irgendwie äh ähm 66 kontrollierte Studien
äh so siebenundsechzig äh Prozent improofment for early Tre,
und äh ja scheint also super zu funktionieren.
Wenn man sich dann auf der Seite gibt's auch Statistiken für alle anderen Mittel so unter anderem auch für verschiedene Vitamine und für Aspirin und so.
Dann stellt man fest, dass laut dieser Seite auch diese Mittel alle super gegen äh äh covid helfen.
Aber der Punkt bei all diesen Mitteln ist natürlich, was man halt ganz klar weiß, Vitamine helfen.
Nur, wenn ich ein Vitamindefizit habe. Was zum Beispiel im Fall von Vitamin D bei vielen Leuten der Fall ist, weswegen dann grundsätzlich Gabe von Vitamin D zum Beispiel tatsächlich hilfreich.
Sein kann so. Aber es hilft halt eben nur in bestimmten Fällen. Und bei ähm,
ist es äh weil man vielleicht auch noch sagen muss, also für die Entdeckung von äh Ivermectin äh gab's einen Nobelpreis.
Und im Grunde genommen ist kann man so wie einen auch wie einen.
Art Spezielles Antibiotikum äh sehen, nur dass es halt äh vor allem gegen Parasiten und äh äh Würmer äh hilft und äh deswegen auch einen Segen für weite Teile der der Menschheit.
Ist, äh die halt von ziemlich üblen Wurmkrankheiten äh betroffen äh sind. Da gibt es dann irgendwie sogenannte Flussblindheit. Ist das fieseste, wo äh dann sich Würmer in deinen Augen vermehren und so und du blind wirst?
Äh davon plus äh was man jetzt festgestellt hat, dass in Gegenden, wo.
Halt Belastung mit Parasiten sehr hoch ist, wenn man dort die normale Behandlung fährt. So die äh gegen gegen covid. Die wiederum auch äh immun äh Supressoren also.
Steroide äh äh dort gibt. Ähm so führt das bei den Leuten, die halt die
Würmer haben, wo das Immunsystem, die aber normalerweise in in Schach hält, ist, dass wenn man die dann gegen covid behandelt mit der normalen Behandlung, dass dann die Würmer die Leute killen, weil das Immunsystem halt unterdrückt wird. So das heißt in den Fällen
äh so wo man dann einfach äh egal ob jemand jetzt Würmer hatte oder nicht äh gegeben hat in den Gegenden, äh hat.
Sich halt äh äh ja hat das halt äh wirklich super geholfen, ne, dass die Leute nicht dann an den Würmern äh gestorben äh sind.
Und was es halt auch.
Hilfreich machen also ist an sich auch 'nen relativ sicheres Medikament. So,
ähm und zwar, das habe ich mir dann auch angeschaut. Also es gibt äh es gibt dann so die.
Von der FBA eine eine Zulassung, die die Empfehlung ähm dass ähm,
ja, man ungefähr Moment ich gucke, gucke hier grad mal äh damit ich nichts,
falsches äh äh Sager. Ja also Dosen, also das Dosis-Limit des FBA-Limit ist so 0,2 Milligramm.
Pro Kilogramm. Äh jetzt für die normalen Behandlungen und äh in Studien, äh so ist die Empfehlung null,2 bis null Komma vier.
Äh zu nehmen. Die höchste Studie, die ich gesehen habe, war so ein Milligramm, also fünf bis fünffache von der FTA-Dosis.
Und es gibt Studien, die vor langer Zeit gemacht wurden, wo man mal geguckt hat äh wie hoch kann man das denn dosieren, bevor es gefährlich wird?
Und da
ist es so, ähm ja, dass bis ungefähr einer zehnfachen Dosis, also zwei äh Milligramm pro Kilo äh Körpergewicht äh hat man halt an gesunden Erwachsenen,
geguckt.
Äh wie hoch man dosieren kann und äh ja zwei Milligramm also bis zwei Milligramm, das Zehnfache der der FDA äh Dosis äh so hat das jetzt,
keine großen Schäden angerichtet, aber es ist unterdrückt halt äh ja dass das die Aktivität des Nervensystems
und äh so ähm ja über die irgendwie äh äh Rezeptoren und ähm.
Ja äh man,
stirbt also an an Vergiftung, aber äh und man man sieht es halt daran, also wie die das in den Studien gemacht haben, dass sie halt geguckt haben, wie weit sich die Pupillen der Leute weiten und hat dann eben irgendwann aufgehört äh,
höher zu dosieren, äh weil ja es dann gefährlich wird so.
Also mit anderen Worten erstmal an sich ist ein sicheres und verträgliches
Mittel für eben eine ganze Reihe von von äh Krankheiten und äh die Leute, die das da jetzt überdosiert haben, müssen also
gewaltige Dosen müssen, also ich sage mal fünfzig oder Hundertfache wahrscheinlich oder das zigfache jedenfalls geschluckt haben äh von von dem
äh was eigentlich die die ja zulässige Dosis ist. Das ist sagen die eine Sache äh und.
Wegen der Sicherheit kann man das eben in bestimmten Gegenden halt auch ähm.
Präventiv geben. So weshalb auch Ivan Mectin, also weswegen diese ganze Welle so losgegangen ist, es war, dass man.
Ivan Mctin halt auch eine der Substanzen war, die äh im in
also sprich im Reagenzglas oder in ja im.
Im Labor äh als man geguckt hat, äh wie sehr es denn die Enzymaktivität
Hemd äh von der äh drei CL Prothease. Es ist ein ein Enzym, was halt die das Virus braucht, um sich vermehren zu können. Dann konnte man halt sehen, okay ähm
bei äh einer.
Größenordnung, also von bei einer Konzentration ab zehn Mikromol äh so beginnt es.
Labor die Aktivität zu unterdrücken und bei 1hundert Mikromol äh äh unterdrückt ist sie praktisch komplett. Ja das heißt äh in dem
Bereich liegt es und da hat sich halt Ivermectin auch mit allen also im Vergleich mit allen anderen antiviralen Substanzen.
Äh als äh ja ziemlich weit vorne oder als Winner äh sogar ist es halt.
Rausgekommen und das äh war dann vermutlich so der Grund, warum halt viele plötzlich gesagt haben, oh wow, das ist es.
Mich dann einfach mal hingesetzt und mal umgerechnet äh was sind denn diese zehn bis 1hundert äh Mikromol? Äh was müsste man den Leuten denn dann tatsächlich an Dosen verabreichen, damit man in diesen
Wirkungsbereich hineinkommt und ähm.
Da kam ich dann halt auf die das Vierzig-fache der FBA äh Dosis, um.
Dahin zu kommen, wo es anfängt zu wirken und das Vierhundertfache der Dosis ähm wo es dann die 100 Prozent äh Enzymaktivität äh unterdrückt so. Das heißt selbst,
Wenn man jetzt hingeht und sozusagen die maximale, ich sage mal zehnfache Überdosierung äh nimmt, ist man immer noch Faktor vier äh weg äh von dem Punkt, wo es im Labor äh Wirkung,
zeigt. So das heißt dass äh ja ähm dass es einfach was was jetzt so die Unterdrückung von
Enzymaktivität angeht man eben nicht auf die notwendigen Dosen äh äh kommt oder wenn man die notwendigen Dosen nehmen würde, dann äh ja äh würde man halt ans an Vergiftung äh sterben.
Und ähm ja das ist äh sozusagen der Punkt ähm was halt übrig bleibt ist,
aber das ist schon eine gewisse äh dass es eine gewisse.
Äh Wirkung,
gibt statistisch äh gesehen. Die sagt zum einen ganz sicher im Zusammenhang jetzt mit mit den Würmern, aber äh so meine Vermutung äh war
dass es ja noch irgendwas gibt, was wir nicht genau
Wissen äh so äh also für möglicherweise noch weitere Faktoren oder ähm oder.
Konstellationen, wo es wo's Wirkung zeigt und gibt eben auch viele Ärzte, die drauf schwören und sagen irgendwie, wir haben das gemacht und wir hatten irgendwie super Erfolge.
Jetzt auch nicht überbewerten, weil das hatten wir bei allen Wundermitteln, aber selbst wenn man auf sowas vielleicht noch zu erwähnen ist.
Es gab halt auch äh mehrere Skandale im Zusammenhang jetzt mit den mit den Studien. Es mussten es gab Datenfälschungen äh bei bei Studien und andere wirklich
fragwürdige Studien und wenn man die rausgenommen hat
ähm hat sich auch in den Meta-Studien sozusagen einen Effekt, der Anfangs zu sehen war, äh praktisch in nichts aufgelöst. Also in ist statistisch nicht signifikant.
Aber selbst wenn man jetzt wirklich ganz kritisch rangeht und da hat halt sich wirklich auch jemand die Mühe äh mal
gemacht und ist wirklich alle Studien, also irgendwie 40 Studien durchgegangen und hat.
Nochmal geguckt, so okay, welche Tauben, welche taugen nichts und wenn man jetzt alle rausschmeißt, die
irgendwie auch nur ein bisschen anrüchig sind von der Meteodologie oder nicht nicht gut sind, bleiben halt trotzdem nur ein paar solide Studien,
übrig, äh die halt äh nach wie vor eine leicht positive Wirkung äh äh zeigen.
Und äh mit anderen Worten ähm so, es ist.
Es ist irgendwo was dran äh so aber äh nicht viel. Ja das wäre das wäre vielleicht äh das das Ding und
Ähm ja und das
als Prophylaxe äh zu nehmen oder so ähm ja. Also ich würd's nicht tun. So, ihr habt dann gesagt, okay
So wenn ich das jetzt hätte und jetzt würde ein Arzt auf mich zukommen dann in der Klinik und fragt, wir machen hier einen äh so. Können wir ihnen das geben?
Äh das das Mittel würde ich jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen okay nicht weil ich glauben würde äh dass es jetzt.
Wirklich wirkt oder hilft, sondern weil es jetzt eben zum einen in,
Dosen unter klinischer Aufsicht äh jetzt nicht besonders gefährlich äh zu sein scheint und
unter Umständen vielleicht hilft, aber ich würd's eher tun, um quasi sagen
ja den wissenschaftlichen Fortschritt zu helfen und nicht weil ich glauben würde äh dass es hilft und auf gar keinen Fall natürlich würde ich jetzt anfangen irgendwie dieses Zeug zu schlucken oder gar vielleicht auch noch äh
die ähm Präparate, die eben für Tiere äh vorgesehen sind, das ist halt völliger Irrsinn, weil
äh dort halt auch noch Stoffe drin sind, also nicht nur jetzt der Wirkstoff, sondern andere Stoffe, die jetzt äh das entweder stabilisieren oder für die Aufnahmen gar keine Ahnung hat, was die im Menschen wirklich anrichten. Also das ist dann kompletter.
Irrsinn, äh ja. Insofern äh ja, auf der einen Seite, wie gesagt, ist nicht ist kein Wundermittel so.
Für äh bestimmte Fälle oder Bereiche wie gesagt einen Segen gerade bei den Leuten, die Wurmbefall haben
dass das mitzugeben und es gibt wahrscheinlich irgendwo noch eine kleine Wirkung, einen kleinen Wirkmechanismus, der jetzt wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viel mit der Enzymaktivität zu tun hat, vermute ich, sondern das macht halt auch noch was anderes, ist,
halt auch das Bike Protein und es verklebt die äh ACE,
zwei ähäh Rezeptoren.
So äh in insofern ja äh ist es jetzt nicht halt
Ich sage mal, kompletter Schwachsinn äh so, aber es ist jetzt auch kein äh äh Wundermittel, was uns irgendwie nennenswert hilft
jetzt die Epidemie äh zu überstehen. Da gibt's jetzt noch ein paar andere wenige Kandidaten, irgendwo einer vom äh äh Pfizer äh unter anderem. So.
Mit äh das ist so ein Mittel mit einer ziemlich kryptischen Nummer, was äh in völlig niedrigeren Dosen tatsächlich,
wirkt und wo man die Hoffnung hat, dass man das hoch genug dosieren kann, dass es eben über die als äh irgendwie Prothease-Hemmer, also die Enzymaktivität einschränkt, ohne dass man dabei stirbt.
Pax Luvita heißt das, ne?
Ja, ist das, ist das, was man als PaxloVit.
Also Merk hatte noch ein anderes von Pfizer, das heißt Pax, äh Louise und das blockt halt so ein wichtiges Enzym, was halt äh ja wohl ganz gut funktioniert.
Muss man halt auch in der Kombination äh noch nehmen mit einem mit einem anderen.
Mittel, damit sich das nicht so schnell abbaut äh und so und äh ja, nur da ist die Situation.
Gab's jetzt einen Trial in in UK, äh der wohl Speck so spektakuläre Ergebnisse geliefert hat, dass man ihn abgebrochen hat?
Aus äh ethischen Gründen, äh weil es irgendwie nicht verantwortbar war, das Placebo zu geben, wo die Medizin äh so gut wirkt. Problem ist,
Wir wissen das halt alles nur aus einer Pressemeldung von Pfizer.
Studien dazu sind weder veröffentlicht noch peer reviewd äh äh bisher. Insofern äh ja können wir mal hoffen
dass da was was dran ist, aber wenn man sagen die selben Maßstäbe an äh an diese neuen Mittel wie an Evamektin
anlegt, dann ist die Studienlage von irgendwie zehnmal besser oder hundertmal besser.
Als äh jetzt von den von den neuen Mitteln, wo es praktisch nichts gibt außer an der Pressemeldung, dass sie ganz toll äh funktionieren. Wie gesagt, was ich.
Ich hoffe, dass es der Fall ist, äh dass sich das rausstellt so, aber wenn man jetzt einfach nur mit kritischem Abstand äh äh hinguckt.
Äh so ja ähm.
Und mein Mann gibt's äh Sachen, Indien hat jetzt aufgehört zum Beispiel Evermedien äh äh zu verwenden, so weil ja,
es eben keine Evidenz wirklich für die für die Wirksamkeit gibt außer in bestimmten Mitteln.
Ja, fällt mir gerade ein, ähm so.
Für Leute also ist unter anderem wohl auch potenziell krebserregend. Insofern äh vielleicht noch als äh letzter Punkt, sodass man das nicht einfach irgendwie als Lutschbonbons äh schlucken sollte.
Gut ähm.
Dann würde ich sagen, kommen wir langsam äh zum Ende. Äh ich habe noch ein paar äh kleine äh äh Nettigkeiten äh für die Shownotes. Da könnt ihr mal reinschauen. Da findet ihr ohnehin ja immer alle Links, die so weit gehen, das, was wir hier so behaupten
hm auch irgendwie belegen.
In den äh gibt's ein Link gibt's vier Links auf vier Videos. Da gibt's auch noch ein bisschen mehr zu finden. Das ist so ein spezielles äh Aufklärungsprojekt, das heißt äh Projekt,
Die haben ein paar interessante Videos, die haben aber vor allem ein paar sehr schöne Animationen, ist auch schon auf Twitter vier umgegangen, habt ihr wahrscheinlich schon mal gesehen, aber da habt ihr's nochmal so als YouTube-Links ähm sehr gelungene 3D Animationen wie
das Virus, wie wir ihn generell Zellen angreifen, aber dann eben auch speziell wie die mRNA und aber auch die äh Vektor äh Vaccine, also Astreid Sinnika
Co funktionieren und auch noch mal äh wie das ähm Immunsystem an sich funktioniert.
Gar nicht so lang sind nur so ein, zwei Minuten Dinger fand ich aber alle sehr schön.
Sie sind wirklich, wirklich toll. Ja, das einzige ähm was man vielleicht noch dazu sagen
muss äh so in Wirklichkeit äh läuft es alles oder laufen viele dieser Vorgänge ungefähr tausendmal so schnell ab äh wie sie im Video zu sehen sind.
Man kann die Videos, also die äh nicht nicht alle Sequenzen, aber äh äh sagen, es ist gleichzeitig noch
extrem äh Zeitlupe, ja, wenn man sich wirklich anguckt, äh was äh äh was da los ist äh sozusagen wie wie schnell jetzt tatsächlich
so RNA kopiert oder exprimiert äh wird äh oder.
So äh da reden wir äh von äh teilweise von Takten im im im Kiloherz. Da reden wir dann äh teilweise von, ich sage mal.
Tausend Basenpaaren pro Sekunde oder so, die da
gelesen werden, zumal das Ganze auch ein hochparalleller Prozess noch ist. Das passiert halt nicht nur an einer Stelle äh sondern also in Wirklichkeit ja äh ähm
sind die Zellen arbeiten schon mit einem äh ganz äh äh mit einem recht hohen Prozess. Ähm sage ich mal.
Ja ich bin äh also ehrlich gesagt ich wollte gerade noch hinzufügen ich hätte es mir noch gewünscht wir werden noch ein bisschen langsamer und noch ein bisschen ausführlicher gewesen ähm noch sehr viel mehr würde ich mir mal so was mal interaktiv wünschen.
Ein bisschen rumklicken kann, aber ich finde es fördert doch extrem wie schon auch die anderen Videos, die wir ja schon vor einiger Zeit mal verlinkt haben äh das Verständnis.
Sehr. Also ähm.
Also es ist extrem gut gemacht. Also es ist das Beste, was ich je gesehen habe zu dem Thema, muss ich ganz klar äh sagen, mit ich sage mal den den meisten äh äh Details auch.
Richtig zusammengefasst und äh also doch sehr großartig, kann ich nur empfehlen. Ist auch sind auch sehr kurz, sollte sich jeder ruhig mal anschauen.
Genau und ganz zum Schluss noch ein Link auf den auf einen Artikel bei Riffreporter, die sich äh ohnehin sehr verdient machen, um die Covid Kabarett und der ist aber auch frei verfügbar.
Der fasst nochmal so ein bisschen die Story zusammen, wie dir das eigentlich so gelaufen ist vor knapp zwei Jahren, als SARS-CoV-zwei das erste Mal auf die Bühne trat und äh konkret, wie eben in der Charité das Team um,
Drosten und Korman da in diesen neuen PCR-Test entwickelt haben und äh welche Strategien sie da an den Tag gelegt haben, können wir vielleicht auch immer nochmal,
hier aufgreifen, aber jetzt einfach nochmal so als Schonus, weil jetzt müssen wir nämlich hier Schluss machen. Ich habe äh noch was zu tun.
Mal noch irgendwie eine Zeit für ein Schlusswort, für einen optimistischen.
Da bist du ja immer der Experte dafür, ne? Das probier doch mal.
Ja, also ähm die meisten von uns werden's überleben. So.
Das ist jetzt äh ich ich sage mal äh das Beste an an Optimismus.
Das ist ja super. Geil.
Ich jetzt grade äh so also es wird nicht also die Welt wird nicht untergehen äh jetzt aber ansonsten ja ist es ist es einfach zum Heulen. Äh so ist es zum Heulen.
Insbesondere jetzt was den politischen,
Kontext angeht, wenn man guckt worauf sich denn die Politik jetzt vorbereitet hat.
Ja. So im Sommer mal sagen, okay, es gibt so drei Möglichkeiten, wie es laufen kann so. Best Case ist.
Wir kriegen irgendwie genug Leute durchgeimpft und bleiben,
verschont von einer extremen Welle, so. Die zweite Variante so, ich sage mal, die.
Auch die wahrscheinlichste äh die absehbar war. Ja, es äh wir werden,
keine ausreichend hohen hohe Impfquote kriegen plus die Impfstoffe werden bisschen in ihrer Wirkung nachlassen. Wir kriegen also eine fette neue
Welle im Herbst. Das war die wahrscheinlichste Variante und die Worst Case war, äh wir kriegen nochmal
eine neue Variante, die nochmal super viel krasser ist, die komplett den bisherigen Impfschutz aushebelt
und wir alle noch mal komplett neu impfen müssen mit einem neuen Impfstoff, äh der gegen
die neuen Varianten hilft. So, worauf hat sich die Politik jetzt vorbereitet, irgendwie auf den unwahrscheinlichen Best-Case? Noch nicht mal auf den wahrscheinlichen Case und erst recht nicht auf den Worst Case, von dem wir bisher zum Glück noch
verschont geblieben äh worden sind, ja, aber das ist so ein bisschen, wo man dann sagen kann, äh ja, das das.
Darf doch alles nicht wahr sein, ja? Es darf doch alles nicht wahr sein
Aber äh gut. Und wie du schon anfangs richtig sagtest, wir haben jetzt äh mehr Tote als äh China Infizierte, so wobei man, klar bei Chinas, soll man aufpassen, aber größenordnungsmäßig kommt es sehr wahrscheinlich hin.
Ja also unser Handling äh war auf jeden Fall jetzt nicht besser als das von China. Das kann man glaube ich mal locker äh sagen. Aber äh das kann man auch verstehen, weil China ist ja eine Insel.
Weißt du und äh von daher sind solche Vergleiche überhaupt nicht zu ziehen. Damit entlassen wir euch in die äh Woche. Äh wir werden hier,
ich vermute mal so vielleicht äh also nicht in einer Woche, aber vielleicht so in anderthalb oder zwei Wochen noch mal ein Update machen. Ich verspreche jetzt erst mal gar nichts, aber wir bleiben natürlich dran am Thema, weil jetzt ist ja demnächst eh wieder Lockdown und dann haben wir wieder viel Zeit.
Ja
Ja, ja. Alright, bis bald. Tschüss.
Okay, dann macht's gut, passt auf euch auf und äh ja, bis demnächst.